H: Good morning John! We're at the food farm and we are here acquiring supplies
for the Second Annual Hungry Games.
Which is basically when some friends and I play a stupid game and if you win the stupid game,
you get to eat something delicious stuffed inside of a dessert.
M: Peanut Butter.
H: And if you lose, you have to eat something super terrible...
stuffed inside a dessert.
E: Oh my god...
This year, instead of cookies, we're having brownies and instead of just two contestants, we're having three.
Myself, Michael Aranda, and Emily Graslie.
E: *laughs*
H: Let's make some brownies.
E: We're making brownies!
E: Oh no...
H: So there's two components to the Hungry Games...
One is we're gonna eat food cause we're hungry,
And two, those fish are also hungry.
M: For my fishing pole...
H: There's a great deal on the line right now.
H: Don't screw up.
E: I'm... suddenly...
H: Yep!
E: Not excited for this.
H: You agreed!
H: YESYESYES!!!
H: I got like, a million.
E: I feel noxious all of a sudden and we haven't even eaten any.
M: Just gonna... not look and take this one.
E: This one.
E: It smells like sriracha. It is pretty good.
H: Yeah?
E: I really like this
E: I can probably eat the rest of this actually...
H: There's a trash can right here.
M: Stand right over it.
E: What is it?
H: I think it's caviar. Maybe caviar tastes good.
E: I'm gonna start putting sriracha in all my brownies from now on...
H: I'll try.
M: Anyone wanna try a caviar brownie?
E: I kinda do.
H: AHH AHH AHH
M: You like this? This smells weird.
H: *coughing and gagging*
E: This tastes like crap!
H: MY FACE!!!
M: And Hank won this round.
*collective laughing*
M: It tasted like nothing.
E: No, this tasted like reproductive organs.
H: Michael reigns supreme!
E: Ooooooh!
E: That was a big bite.
M: You got right in there.
E: *laughter*
H: It's a fish stick...
M: Oh dude, I was kinda hoping for that one.
M: I really like fish sticks.
H: Right yeah! Right in there!
E: Oh my god...
H: Is it beans?
E: I think it is, yeah. I still feel like I lucked out.
H: What do you got?
M: Peanut Butter.
*Emily and Hank groan*
E: Alright. SHOOP SUGAR SUGAR SUGAR
H: Aww...
E: Did I win!? I won!!
E: I need a nap...
E: What is it?
H: Horseradish...
E: Oh yaaay! I didn't get that one!
H: AUGGGGH
E: I thought you liked horseradish!
H: Instead of chocolate and horseradish, it's chocolate and horseradish and spit!
H: Oh noooo! I'm so happy right now!
H: You're handling this very well...
E: How is it?
M: Fine... it's a little cheesy.
E: It's not- oh...
H: Michael has 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10...
E: 5, 6, 7, 8, 9... :(
H: OOOOH
M: WOOOO
H: I think you got the peas... I got the spam!
E: I got the peas!
E: I don't like wasabi peas at all... I don't like it!
H: Mine has spam in it... 3, 2, 1. *noms*
H: Negative feeling about this. OH! There's so many chunks!
M: *incomprehensible* it's hard. I'm just gonna suck on it for a while.
E: I'm still kinda hungry...
M: All I can think of at this point is "how are we going to outdo this for next year?"
H: Glad you're ready for this to happen next year!
H: What am I doing??
H: Thank you for joining me, both Michael and Emily. Thank you to Stephan for filming.
This was a delicious evening interspersed with really terrible experiences.
M: Goodbye John.
H: See ya Tuesday!